Adam I gotta talk to you you've been
working with all these guys we've been
working with norm yeah we you've worked
for him with him for a long time yeah we
all have been we all know each other as
long you know forever I mean a spade and
Schneider used to live all the right
across the street from each other since
we're like 20 years old asam back and
sports when we don't know that well but
Normie
no I think we just bring it up was when
me and norm mean or when we did Billy
Madison I said I would tell ya oh yeah
yeah so that's like the first time you
guys worked together in a movie right
yeah okay I mean it was the first there
was there our first movie hey we're
right here right here yeah yeah so no
and I did the movie enormous I we didn't
know each other's acting stuff right so
me and my best friend were at the pool
we're doing a pool scene I'm Billy
Madison of course so old Billy's gonna
talk to you a Frank I played Frank
you're gonna turn and clarify everything
I get nervous with Norman behind it I
saw anyway so I I I'm doing a scene with
norm at the pool and I tell them I say
my line I think I did it very well
and then I I'm like let me see how norm
you know ping-pong is this line back
there's a little bit of a delay and I
was like old norm likes to take his time
yeah
an acting tech maybe maybe he's going
deep for this yeah right
and then I'm waiting a little longer and
I'm like wow he's really milking this
one and then a few more seconds I
noticed a little norm was sleeping sleep
while the camera was rolling well they
wanted me to play a drunk and so I said
got some booze also he called me Frank
and in my mind I was thinking who though
[Applause]
I think you weren't ad gonna I just
realized that I'm basically in the
audience
[Laughter]
now David I'm asking something I
understand that on this here comes the
funny tour there's a group chat yes that
you guys have engaged in how's that
going well obviously we all just make
fun of each other and yeah Rob got a
good one in aa Adam because Adams not
off limits he really pretends to be one
of the guys and I used to say I'm fair
game but uh Rob goes hey Adam you know
when you do the show you should tape it
and then you see where the jokes don't
work and then take those jokes out of
your head put better ones any goes
that's right know about the private jet
sometimes Adams nice enough to actually
let us go up front where he says thank
you
you